e
and I'm sorry for the delay I'm going to
call uh the Judiciary Committee to order
and would you please uh rise and join me
Allegiance I pledge allegiance to the
flag of the United States of America and
to the repic for which stands one nation
under God indivisible with liy and
thank you and with that I'm going to
open uh the executive session on the six
bills that we uh have to exec and uh
first I'm going to turn to uh Senate
Bill
185 and uh the chair recognized
representative Alexander for a motion
thank you Mr chair I move in expedient
to legislate is there a second for that
I second seconded by representative
cutab representative Alexander do you
wish to speak to your motion yeah very
briefly so um the senate in their
Infinite Wisdom likes to send us a lot
of study committees um and I think that
one of these I think that some of them
are sorely needed I voted for some of
them but some of them um we already know
what the barriers are this is a
committee to study the barriers
discharged for patients I'm looking
currently at a um release by the
hospital Association foundation for
healthy families that basically says
that barriers such as Medicaid
enrollment housing and security secure
Guardianship and the need for
specialized Services creat significant
roadblocks to discharge so that seems to
me like they know what the barriers are
so um I think that they're doing their
own independent study on what they can
do on their end to fix it so in this way
I don't think that we need another study
committee on something that we know what
the barriers are right uh yes
representative Oregon and then
representative Smith I mean I don't
necessarily disagree with anything the
representative Alexander said but I
think the study committee and well it's
only going to meet for a short time
anyway but I think they might then be
able to move on at least examine the
issue of what more can be done about
those barriers we I guess even if we do
know what the barriers are it knowing
what the barriers are is kind of not
very helpful if we don't do anything
about it and maybe they can represent
some actual actions I mean I know that
involves doing things differently and
possibly even spending more money but it
I I I think it might I think it would be
a useful exercise convening that group
of six people a few times over the
summer and fall and putting out putting
out the report even though it's not
going to solve the problem so I'm going
to I would be cined to vote against the
itl all right uh representative
Smith thank you Mr chair I agree
completely with
everything that um
representative Alexander said um except
I would add one more thing
immediately which is that this bill
should not have come to this committee
it should have gone
to um Health and Human Services they
have the history on all of this we do
not um and we shouldn't have ever taken
it we did and once we held a hearing
we're locked into it having said that
this to me parallels it's exactly the
same um as the situation we had on
certain mental health issues where the
thought was that all the people who were
primarily involved weren't able on their
own to solve the problem even though
that's what they're paid to do and
instead the legislature should act like
the mother and father and say now you
must you know you must take your
medicine you must do what you're
supposed to do I don't like playing that
role I I really am offended by that role
because I expect to have three equal
branches where we set the
policy and and the executive branch
is and I don't think we're going to
accomplish a
thing and I've been very clear about
that to my to my my caucus I've been
clear about that I don't think this is
going to accomplish a thing however as I
see yet again that the um The Campaign
that particularly the hospital
Association and others has the energy to
uh to carry out the campaign to make
sure everybody knows about the study and
the problems but not to do the solutions
maybe it's true that they can't do it
without us and we ought to acknowledge
that they're not capable or competent or
committed enough to solve their own
problems and therefore at least what we
ought to do is pass it have a committee
have them come in and say the same
things they could say without the
committee and then end up with
legislation perhaps that we could
recommend for the next legislature that
might be more
um
directed in terms of stepping in where
we shouldn't have to where they should
solve it on their own so that's my
personal dilemma thank you uh rep
restive
Andrew thank you Mr chair I agree with
the itl I have listened to the hospital
Association etc
etc yes there is a problem but they
should be solving that problem coming up
what needs to be done and bring it to
the legislature I'm offended that they
want a committee and just dump
everything on to the legislature and you
solve all the problems thanks other
people people wish to be heard on this
yes representative Stapleton yeah thank
you uh Mr
chair I know there's problems out there
I'm personally involved with helping a
constituent who was a ward of the state
New Hampshire hospital and he was stuck
there um for want of a bed in a suitable
Nursing Care
Facility um eventually a bed opened up
and he was taken pretty much immediately
because even though there's a backlog in
the Medicaid Department um they took it
on a pending
nursing basis and I would say that a lot
of nursing homes would do that maybe
some won't um but he was 3 months in a
pending
situation and um it it worked out um the
other problem now how are we going to do
anything about that I I don't I don't
understand if there's a backlog in
Medicaid and then there's a backlog in
DHHS um relative to uh guardianships and
um the courts backed up on court
awarding these things uh I don't see how
the legislature can do anything with
that that's got to be from the
Grassroots ground up solve that problem
and uh those are beyond our ability at
least those two to do anything me
meaningful about it with a committee
other comments uh representative tur and
then representative
katab um yeah so I I intend to vote
against the itl motion um again
acknowledging all the things that were
said probably being correct um you
know I think the question of whether or
not this is or isn't a legislative
problem is sort of um not front of mind
for me because you know this is a a
situation that's evolved over a long
time and again coming you know
professionally from the world of healthc
care access and delivery you know the
idea of you know hospital beds sitting
full and
uncompensated you know across the state
it you know given our need for resources
you know is a big enough issue uh that I
think it deserves the attention of all
possible parties and I feel like the the
the commitment here is relative ly low
we were told um that there is data and
that there is information available
that's actionable enough in the time
frame that we have to maybe move the
ball down the court somewhat and and um
you know I don't I don't think the
amount of time that's there is enough to
maybe come up with some comprehensive
solution but I I don't see the problem
with allowing it to happen right
representative
chob so I don't disagree that there's a
problem I completely agree that there's
a problem however
I I think it would be more effective if
if legislators want to work to fix the
problem together with with the
stakeholders got together and did that
on their own in the summer rather than
putting together a formal committee for
it because when you put together a for
formal committee we have leadership that
decides who gets assigned what and you
may even have people that don't even
really aren't even interested in this
topic forced to sit on it vers you could
get I think it would be much more
effective if people that actually wanted
to to take the and put in the work on
this agree to get together and just and
just put it in I just I guess I don't
see why it needs to be a formal
committee and then that of
course creates a lot
more things around it in the sense of
you've got to meet here and it's got to
be in public ver if people meet together
without it being a quorum they can meet
anywhere they want and they can meet on
zoom and I just think that there's a lot
more opportunity for people to be able
to actually address the real problem
because I do think it's going to be a
lot of work and I don't think that it's
something that can just resolve in a
couple of meetings and I'm not sure
depending on who gets put on there their
level of commitment to come in for that
many meetings so I guess for that reason
I think it would be better if it was
done informally thank you other other
comments um yes representative
Lonzo um thank you um so I would just
like to say I will also be voting
against the itl because I do feel that
this is um a very important issue um
with um patients um sitting into the um
emergency rooms trying to um find a u
bed placement somewhere else and I think
that um it is something that we need to
look at and we had a a lot of people
come with concern over this and I think
it's um really very important um to uh
maybe work together um with a study
committee and um yes it did come to our
committee versus uh going to Health and
Human Services but since we did hear it
we have to now um decide on this so
thank you so you know I I know
representative Smith I think has
requested a brief recess which I'm going
to which we of course we will take the
before you do that the only thing that
that I would add as a comment of why I
support the itl is I I agree with I
think everything that everybody has said
you may recall when we had the hearing
on this matter I was kind of of the
impression that that even though I
agreed with with all of the criticisms
that representative Smith had had laid
out my sense was kind of where some of
you are now well yeah this is you know
they didn't do what they should what
they should have done but maybe we
should just let the have this study
committee but as I've thought about
it particularly the comments of
Representative Smith she pers she
persuaded me now to take the position of
itl that that I think she would was
originally at least I was under the
impression that she had the would would
have supported and here's my
concern what what I came away from the
hearing with was was the impression that
when this bill was in the other it was
before the
Senate the it wasn't that people didn't
know what Solutions should what the
solutions were or what the issues were
they were very well um uh elaborated and
the problem was they couldn't come to an
agreement they couldn't come to an
agreement on how to solve the problem
and so what they decided to do of course
Let's Kick the Can down the road we'll
have a study commit we'll send it over
to the house and you know we'll kick the
can down the road it's not so much that
they didn't know what to do but they
didn't want to make the hard decisions
and so you know that leads me to think
that
sorry uh having this study committee is
not going to is not going to advance the
ball what needs to happen is the
legislature who has the power to make
the law to to change things needs to do
it and that's that's what should happen
next next year it's too late now but
that's what should happen next year is
there should be some Bill that says
we're going to th this is the this is
the way we solve this problem and and
presumably that will not get you know
that will not get unanimous support but
hopefully it will get it will get a
majority to come to some solution as
opposed to us just you know having this
study committee of us as legislators who
are not really in any way experts in
this area particularly as representative
Smith points out that we're the
Judiciary Committee um so that's why I I
am going to and I am going to vote for
itl but I understand you know
frustration that everybody has
experienced and with that I'm we'll take
a brief let me if I could just add one
thing remember that there would only be
two members of the Judiciary Committee
involve one Democrat and one Republican
only two in the committee that's set up
there so in that sense the plus is only
two of us would have to bear the brunt
the minuses only two of us would be
bearing the brunt um the other thing and
I this is clearly something I should not
say and as you all know I frequently say
things I should not say and that is as
much as I um I thank you for agreeing
with me representative Paris I
appreciate that um uh oh dear the
commissioner's leaving he's afraid I'm
going to say something about
him
um
uh well now that the laughs are over uh
I've been I've been really amused I've
been annoyed but I'll say amused about
the fact that this is the time that the
hospital Association and others have
picked to
publicize their report on how serious
this problem is um and indicating you
know that they have the data to support
it where have they been and to pick it
now I have that problem and I will tell
you that maybe this has nothing to do
with this but I was heart sick to
something I should have been aware of
that I'm haven't been aware of that
CMC is about to go to a for-profit
hospital and um if CMC is going to a
for-profit hospital um by joining
Hospital Corporation of America we're in
real trouble and that's part of my
concern and that last thing I know I
shouldn't have said but I feel it deeply
could I ask my Democrat colleagues to
join us in our luxurious anti room here
for literally 2 minutes and then we'll
be back absolutely we'll take a recess
you
e
F
on uh
185 all right so the motion is uh itl um
and I I guess I would ask the uh clerk
to call the role please Vice chairman
Wallace yes rep Alexander yes rep
Andrews yes rep testerman yes rep
Stapleton yes rep trip yes rep gon yes
clerk tab votes yes rep Perez yes rep
Smith rep Horgan no rep D Lorenzo no rep
Kenny no rep page no rep Divine yes rep
Lonzo no rep Manos no repur no rep Ming
no chairman Lynn
to9 majority okay um representative
Alexander can we ask you to write the
majority to write the report all right
minority
represent representative L okay all
right
second okay all right um next um I'm
going to turn to
uh Senate Bill 413 and I'm going to
recognize
myself uh to offer uh Amendment
20241 167
8h um
which well I and I so I move that is
there a second I second that seconded by
representative
Alexander
1678 yes all right and um I'd like to uh
speak to the motion just very briefly
um this uh motion would not change the
part of of 413 that is now um in the
original bill but it would
add uh
the the sub the substance the exact
substance of of uh House Bill
1115 the bill dealing with uh uh
termination of tency at the end of the
lease to uh the bill as uh Section 8 and
it would r number the effective date to
uh on the original Bill to section 9 UM
as you know the this bill uh the the
landlord tenant bill passed the house by
a vote of I believe it was 194 to 180
which it it seems to me indicates that
there was um at least some bipartisan
support maybe up to 14 or 15 votes it
was a uh not a roll call vote so I don't
know for sure um at any rate the Senate
appears like they have moved in
committee at least to interim study it
um they did not see the wisdom that the
uh that the house saw in this bill uh
perhaps um with this uh uh Amendment to
the Pas bill that will persuade them of
the wisdom of the uh of the landlord
tenant Bill and so that's why I uh offer
this
amendment anyone yes ask a question of
the chair and this will uh present my
ignorance to the whole procedure here in
my second term so is there a gerus
question relative to this and how was
that sorted out no there there isn't and
the reason for that is this we can add
anything to a Senate bill as long as it
was something that has already passed
the house so this passed the house in
EXA word for word and so that's why
there's not a gerine gerain is um anyone
else wish to be heard on
this uh representative Oregon um I I
don't remember exactly but the this bill
will have a 60-day um effective period
so what was the effective period of the
uh previous tendency bill which we're
trying to revive here this well this one
you know this one has a
30-day um oh I'm sorry the when it
becomes effective um
that it was the same I think it was it
was the same yes there's no there was no
change in that all right um so that's
that's it's exactly the same um anyone
else um yes reative Kenny um thank you
Mr chairman so I am not going to you
know resay all the arguments I made last
time we got this bill I didn't like it
as a standalone bill I don't like it um
you know kind of tagged onto this bill
that you know it has nothing to do with
um so I I'm going to vote against it and
I on my colleagues too thank you all
right any other comments all right then
i' ask the clerk to call the role on the
amendment
please Vice chairman Wallace yes rep
Alexander yes rep Andrews rep testerman
yes re Steepleton yes rep trip yes rep
gon yes kab votes yes rep Perez
yes rep Smith no rep organ no rep D
Lorenzo no rep Kenny no rep page no rep
deine no rep lonza no rep Manos no rep t
no rep Ming no chairman Lynn
yes motion fails 10 to
10 all right all right um is there
don't everybody speak at
[Laughter]
once I
um I move out to pass there
second second all right so hang on um
so moved by representative
Oregon all right uh representative Smith
do you wish to speak to your motion I
don't think that's necessary thank you
all right anyone else wish to speak
representative Alexander thank you Mr
chair I think there's Merit to this bill
um happy to support contents of it but I
actually think the bill would be further
enhanced by the amendment that just
failed so I'm voting against the ought
to pass right
right anyone else wish to heard so I'm I
I just want to say I'm I'm also going to
vote against the motion of ought to pass
and urge my colleagues to do the same um
I think
um and I understand I understand that
people do not agree with the uh with the
um with the amendment and I I'm fine
with that I guess I would say
to I think primarily to my caucus but
maybe one maybe speak more broadly to
the floor I think we have I think that
there is an Institutional interest of
the house um
to um to preserve its position and I
think we um as I said before the the
this bill the the the bill dealing with
land tenant passed the house on a on a
it wasn't you know a one or two vote
margin it was a 14 or 15 vote margin um
I think the house has an institution
interest in uh in preserving its
position so I hope that uh my CS at
least will vote no on this on this uh
OTP so that we can get it to the floor
um with what I expect will be a 10 to 10
vote and then uh take up and debate the
uh Amendment on the floor so that's
no I'm sorry any other uh comments all
right then I would ask the clerk to to
call the role please on the uh motion of
ought to
pass Vice chairman Wallace No rep
Alexander no rep Andrews no rep
testerman no rep Stapleton no rep trip
no rep gon no clerk attab votes no rep
Perez no rep Smith yes rep Horgan yes
rep D Lorenzo yes rep Kenny yes rep page
yes rep Divine yes rep lonza yes rep
Manos yes repur yes Brett Ming yes
chairman Lynn
no motion veils 10 to
10 um so it'll go to the floor without
recommendation
um I guess I will write the report in
favor of otpa and who will write the
report in favor of OTP I guess I get the
um and ly
okay all right um now I'll turn to um
Senate Bill 4 uh
22 uh and the chair recognizes
2024-the wish to speak to your uh
motion just briefly thank you
so this is simply changing the spots
where unless it was a medical spot from
birth mother to mother and the reason
behind that was if somebody is using a
surrogate or a gestational carrier that
person is the mother but they are not
the birth mother um and I just I think
that while this bill is seeking to
include more people which is wonderful I
don't want to exclude some people that
were already included and I think simply
saying mother would be inclusive to all
situations I did leave birth mother in
the places where it medically made sense
such as the statistical data on if you
had gave given birth before and if the
patient had to be transferred out of the
hospital to another hospital due to a
birth complication of some sort because
that was very obviously meant to be the
person who actually gave birth so uh
that's that's really all that this is is
changing in there and I think that it's
a good idea
that we make sure that when we're using
mother we're inclusive of of the
different families that we might have
thank you anyone else wish to speak to
uh representative kav's
motion this is 97 correct 16978 16978
yeah all right so I guess um are we
ready uh for a vote on this and I I
guess what I would say is I I I agree
with representative katab I intend to
vote um in favor of this amendment and I
understand there may be another
amendment but I'm going to vote in favor
of this one for now um all right are we
ready for uh to call the role right ask
the clerk to call the rooll
please Vice chairman Wallace yes rep
Alexander yes re Andrews rep testerman
yes rep Stapleton yes rep trip yes rep
gon yes clerk have votes yes rep Perez
yes re Smith yes rep Horgan yes rep D
Lorenzo yes rep Kenny yes rep page yes
rep Divine yes rep lonza yes rep Manos
yes rep tur yes rep Ming yes chairman
Lynn
to0 all right so is there another
amendment and I chair recognize
representative Alexander yes Mr chair I
move amendment number 2024
d698
H is there a
second I'll second it
um representative Alexander do you wish
to uh speak to your motion yeah briefly
Mr chair um this amendment I believe um
adopts all of the changes we just made
with representative kab's Amendment but
further adds house positions that the
Senate has chosen to um study further um
or not study at all um these two
positions that have already passed the
house include the landlord tenant bill
that we just passed um um or that we
just voted on an amendment um with the
Le expiration of lease as well as the
repeal of a um unneeded court reporter
license that um we've already vetted
through this committee so I hope that my
colleagues will consider supporting this
amendment it makes those small changes
with represent cab but also adds our
previous positions
thanks anyone else wish to be heard on
that so I'm uh I I I am also going to be
supporting uh represent of Alexander's
Amendment for the reasons that um he
just said uh all right so I ask the uh
clerk to call the role please on uh
Amendment 1698 H Vice chairman Wallace
yes R Alexander yes rep Andrews rep
testerman yes rep Stapleton yes rep trip
yes rep gon yes votes yes rep
Perez rep
Smith rep orgon no rep D Lorenzo no rep
Kenny no rep paage no rep Divine rep
lonza no rep Manos no repur no rep Ming
no chairman Lynn
10 all right
so we are now back
to the
um and I guess I would say for the same
reasons that we discussed earlier um it
would be my intention to vote no on this
um this uh Amendment so that we get the
issue to the floor uh in the most
favorable way to those of us who support
um the otpa that just failed so I would
urge my colleagues to vote no on uh this
amendment um so that we as I said are in
the most favorable position when the
when this matter gets to the floor
anyone else wish to be heard on
this all right then I would ask the
clerk to uh call the role please Vice
chairman Wallace No rep Alexander rep
Andrew r testerman no r stepleton no R
trip no gon no clar kab votes no rep
Perez rep Smith yes rep Horgan yes rep D
Lorenzo yes rep Kenny yes rep page rep
Divine yes rep lonza yes rep Manos yes
repur yes rep Ming yes chairman Lynn
no 10 to 10 10 to
10 so um
the
um the bill will go to the floor without
uh recommendation and um representative
katab would you write the report fa no
I'm sorry representative Alexander would
you write the report uh favoring the
otpa with your Amendment and who will
write
right not
represent right that was a uh it was a
TI vote on so that failed right so so on
otpa it's
otpa with
representative 69
697 1697
right but does but you know right but
doesn't that I mean the the amendment
that failed would still go to the floor
would it
not but not on the otpa otpa would be
only
1697 okay then there would be um a
motion of
OT there would be another motion of
otpa with
1698 right okay and um uh it would be up
to the speaker to decide which OTP go
goes first I would assume he well I
can't speak um he will decide which one
goes first but you have we have to have
two different performs right right
exactly so so there are two different
there there's the otpa TPA that right
and so um representative kav you will
write the one with your Amendment does
that make
sense does represent Kai want to put
himself in that position
I think if I can jump in I think that
one caucus has taken a position of otpa
with 1698 and one caucus has taken the
position of otpa with 1697 so um I'm
happy to write the report for the the
the Republican caucus that has voted
with 1698 okay if one of my colleagues
across the aisle will write the other
report sure that's fine somebody on the
other side want to write the report for
um so uh who moved and seconded the the
No No the next
motion Smith so I will do I'm sorry
Smith and Horgan yeah yeah that's right
I will do o t p a 1697 and Alexander
will do
okay
16 and when are these do Mr chair um I'd
like to have those I'd like to have them
all in tonight by the end of the the end
of the day today if we can
please H hang on just one second let me
just give me one second uh
um
I I just wanted to clarify one thing
that I'm struggling in my head which is
otpa
um they will reflect different vote
counts because we did did we actually
take an otpa vote on the first on the
Second Amendment or the first amendment
I should say yes did both we did on both
the first one first
one p 20 to the first Amendment right
but did we actually vote the bill that
yes yes we did okay all right right we
um all right
so I'm purely speculating here but we
didn't vote we didn't vote otpa on the
second on the Second Amendment because
it it had failed failed I'm sorry yes it
failed so that was actually what I meant
so okay okay am and then the bill the
bill okay right all right
so all right
the specul here but the disagreement was
of course over the landlord tenant thing
that was snuck in but probably the court
reporter thing I maybe I shouldn't say
that for sure but probably that has
bipartisan supports so if we get
deadlocked on the floor there's always
the option probably to divide the
question and take out that landlord
tenant thing and that would probably I
but that's like but that's like a few
days away so it's probably not for me to
worry about but I just mentioned that is
just thinking ahead strategically like
it's
probably right I I'm pretty sure our
caucus doesn't mind the court reporter
part we all I think we all voted for it
before I don't think you can speak no I
can't sorry you're right yeah just speak
s yeah yeah we that's true we have it
representative Manos I I also have a
procedural question um if representative
okay all right any other all right so
we're ready to move on then to uh Senate
Bill
um and the
uh chair recognizes uh representative
trip for a motion I uh move interim
study is there a second for
that second all right um representative
trip do you wish to speak to your motion
well I remember two and a half hours of
testimony on this and uh it's it's clear
to me that uh uh there's
some uh attention as to you know
uh what the problem is and what the
solution is so I I believe that uh an
interim study uh committee would help to
resolve these
problems anyone else representative
tur uh yeah i' also speak in favor of
interim study um you know we heard a lot
of testimony about what could have or
maybe should have been done by way of
prior
analysis um in terms of Actuarial
studies around the impacts of you know
changing this law we heard fairly
Divergent um discussion about what that
impact might be in the absence of an
actu study um you know from minimal to
nothing to you know catastrophic um so
everyone seem to acknowledge that
the um the number that was in the amend
bill from the Senate was not a number
that came from any particular place
other than a desire to walk back a full
you know uh repeal of the cap um and
so uh I would like to see that Actuarial
study done you know particularly whether
or not the hospital Association and
Dartmouth and the others that came you
know from the from the provider side on
the medical aspects of liability
concerned um if if you know given given
the loss of half of the maternity Wards
in in the state over the last you know
couple of decades um I I I feel like
moving forward with this without that
knowledge would be difficult and I would
hope and I know there's been some
questions about what this study would
actually do that it would take into
account not just the change to the cap
on the death um versus the disability
side of things but all the different
variations that we heard in terms of how
New
Hampshire's um Los of
Consortium um rules operate versus other
states because it sounded like there was
not just an upside potential for
insurance rates but everyone seemed to
agree the insurance rates are too high
you know overall and becoming
unaffordable and if there's a downside
I'd like to see that Actuarial analysis
take that into account as well all right
other other representative Smith thank
you very much Mr chair I actually
delighted to see sitting in the audience
um the commissioner of the Department of
Insurance I'm always happy to see him
haven't seen him for a number of years
um but I don't really have a question
that I could ask him in All In you know
in in all honesty so I'm just going to
enjoy the fact that he's here and say
that this to me is a Redux of discussion
we had just a few minutes ago and that
is of the
Departments and supposedly in the
executive branch of governor of of
government playing Mommy mayi with the
legislature when they're not willing to
do what they are expected to do we've
heard that there is a highly competent
staff in the insurance department who
could have done the study that we're
waiting for and then they also we've
also been told that there in fact is a
study that does have numbers but somehow
isn't quite ready to get to us it's
exactly the same thing that the hospital
Association has said to us in another
context and um uh there there 20 of us
on this committee not one of us is Henny
Penney the sky is not falling there is
no reason to believe believe and there's
no evidence anywhere that has been
presented to us that the insurance rates
are going to go up or down based on
whether we take a number that was
appropriate many many years ago and try
taking a very small step to bring that
number into um into the current uh uh
world that we live in um I don't know
what we would do um in interim study in
the next few months what would change I
don't know how we're going to be able to
get the Departments that are involved to
grow up and take responsibility for what
they ought to be doing um and so um on
that basis I don't know why we don't
just uh go or to pass and if somebody
can show me anything substantive that
indicates this is the wrong thing to do
I will change my vote immediately but at
at the moment
um uh at least we ought to do something
and this would be doing something thank
you right other representative
Perez representative Smith I agree with
you
100% don't fall over
dead
um we did have test testimony that said
other states have done this and that
testimony was brought to us showing that
their insurance rates did not
necessarily go up and in some cases went
down so my feeling about waiting around
and waiting to see you know you can get
don't get me started on you know it
depends on what question you ask to get
what you want that um um I just think
you're right they have numbers they
didn't present them numbers in other
states were presented in the meantime in
the meantime we have people who could be
getting what they might deserve to get
that are not getting it so I know my um
committee heads are not happy with me
but I definitely believe that there's no
point no point at all in holding off on
this if they want to come back and amend
it later fine let them but my car rates
have gone up and I don't get in an
accident nobody cares about that so I'd
rather go after the insurance companies
for that thank
you uh yes representative Paige I agree
with representative
Perez
representative um well there's a
tradeoff with any type of insurance so
the less benefits so the less ins value
insurance has the at least in theory the
cheaper you can make the price but um I
think this uh I think this pill would uh
people who suffer these damages would be
getting more would be getting like more
in compensation for a loss which really
no amount of money can compensate you
for a s that's a positive thing which
was never really mentioned by those who
are saying oh insurance rates will
Skyrock and I certainly just noticed
that nobody
said which something we could have done
it would have been a Germaine Amendment
oh we should eliminate this and then and
insurance rates are going to plunge you
know nobody was saying that so I I I
think uh I think this does uh get more
money for people who suffer these
damages it still isn't enough so I think
it's I think it's a good bill whether or
not you know we could have a discussion
about whether or not that was the
appropriate amount to raise it by but
certainly hasn't been changed in what
since 1997 so raising it somewhat my
opinion is appropriate even if it does
cause insurance rates to Skyrocket which
they're already doing any anyway so I
think it's a good bill so representative
ma thank you Mr chair um I was reviewing
the testimony in front of the um Senate
Judiciary Committee on this bill and at
that point um commissioner beton Court
said an Actuarial team will take a look
at the underwriting factors and that was
on February 6th if I uh yes February 6th
so um we heard testimony that that
hasn't been done yet from the insurance
department and again um if they had that
information it should have been forth
coming by now um and so I uh I
definitely support this
bill and would oppose interim study all
right anyone else wish to be heard so I
guess what I say is I'm going to support
the interim study um for a couple of
reasons first of all as I said at the
hearing I'm I am at least skeptical of
the um of the impact that this will have
on insurance uh rates but I think it is
true that insurance rates are under
pressure whether this you know this
might be just a um a small factor of
that but there I think we've all seen
that that that rates have gone up um
where we have the insurance industry and
the insurance department and I you know
I'm not sure that we as as I think we
heard at the hearing the insurance
department it's not as if they were
sitting around and the only thing they
had to do was work on an Actuarial study
in this case they have a lot of other
work that they do and so I'm not you
know would it have been better if they
had been far if they had been further
along sure I guess I could say that but
I'm not sure that I'm ready to make a
decision on supporting an increase in
the in this area uh without hearing from
them when you know know it's been uh if
if we put this off till next year before
acting I don't think it's the it's the
end of the world and I think
particularly along with with rep what
representative tur said particularly in
the area of professional liability like
medical malpractice and that kind of
thing I think we have to be very
concerned not just about rates but about
availability of that kind of insurance
uh we sort of went through that kind of
thing of 20 years ago or whatever it was
um and I don't think we want to have
that happen um again the last point I
would make on this is I think that the
um one of the things that as I just said
one of the things that gives me some
skepticism about whether this will be a
big rate increase in the end um the the
flip side of that is that
I the idea that if the if we don't
increase the rates for this kind of loss
of Consortium coverage that this is a
you know a
huge uh miscarriage of Justice I really
take that with with with something of a
grain of salt because as we heard this
is the if a person dies they're they're
they're going to be able to co recover
their damages in their own right
normally the people that benefit from
that are the same people who would
benefit from loss of Consortium there
are honic damages that are available um
on the issue of uh you know the the the
issue of the of the person who is not uh
employed remember the value of the
damages is earning capacity not earnings
so that um that can often make a
difference at any rate for all of those
reasons I think the interim study is the
appropriate thing to do what I would say
is this if we do vote for interim study
and um we're back here next year and
there is not an Actuarial study
available to us
um if I'm back here anyway I know what
my vote is going to be at that point so
hopefully the message uh the message
goes out that we need the interim study
and we need it quickly I mean we need
the the Actuarial study and we need it
quickly representative Smith thank you I
do agree that we need the actual AAL
study I do agree that we need to make
sure that um we do just the facts ma'am
I give the example of the statement that
was made very strongly about why York
hospital closed um its uh its maternity
Division and the uh the very clear and
specific statement made by York Hospital
as to why they closed it that had
nothing to do with insurance it had to
do with other issues that that that
we're aware of um so it's I I always
want to have just the facts ma'am and
that we're not getting the facts has
nothing to do with whether we could it
has to do with the willingness for
example if you check the um
uh the profit I I I'm I'm not opposing
the capitalist system I think it's fine
and the rules are fine and there's
nothing wrong with insurance companies
making a profit but they are making a
profit and they're making the profit
while pretending that the sky is stating
that the sky is falling and it's not
falling and that's why I I'm supporting
supporting the bill and if it comes to
pass that there's facts to show us
that's something different then let's
act on those facts thank you all right
yes representative
Perez we just
passed letting Physicians assistance
have their own
practice which I fought against because
you want to talk about insurance rates
going up for you brought up hospital for
liability those are going to go up like
crazy because of doing that and I didn't
see the insurance companies out fighting
that so I find that it's very
interesting that they're fighting so
hard on something that in my opinion
appears to just be right and too
old representative tur
yes just turned it off just one more um
thought on on sort of the the reason for
the interim study and I guess for me and
believe me I'm not an expert on how
insurance rates are are are set and
approved um and the commissioner can
certainly correct me if I'm incorrect um
but we heard a number of insurance
companies basically claiming that their
um assessment is that this would cause a
potential rate increase which to me
makes me wonder are they then going to
apply for rate increases to um you know
to account for that in the absence of an
Actuarial study you know by the
insurance department that basically can
refute that if in fact the there is not
a rate increase I worry that you know
the studies by the insurers to support
their rate increases might result in
rates going up because we don't have any
information to um question or counter
that so that is my reason partly for um
supporting the the interim study before
going forward with this uh
representative Stapleton thank you Mr
chair um I'm really conflicted with this
bill on the one hand um a life um lost
and Consortium should be at least um
commensurate to the loss in in some
measurable
fashion um and inflation has hit uh the
the limits already stated in in the bill
in the law um just like everything
else on the other hand um looking at the
testimony there was a predominance of
opposition to this and being myself in
the having been in the insurance
industry while you can get uh primary
coverage um pretty well anything over a
million or two in some circumstances has
to go to
reinsurance and there's where the big
uncertainty is um and it can run the
gamut of reasonable to excessive uh and
it's a it's a open market um it's it's
uh difficult to get reinsurance on
extended liability limits and if this
bill were to push this over into that
category there could be some devastating
Insurance impacts on
premiums I think we need the information
and I would like to see further study
impact and the Actuarial study and so
I'm going to go for the interim study
further com yes representative Alexander
thank you Mr chair I think um I agree
with representative Stapleton I think a
true interm study is important on this
um I've had separate Sation with the
insurance commissioner and he indicated
that um he has one actuary on staff so
it's going to cost if if they wanted to
do the study it would cost almost
$100,000 to um Farm it out externally to
have them do that study so I think if
the legislature legislature Works in
tandem with the insurance department and
we study it as well and have a true
interm study I think maybe next year we
can come back with um something that can
raise maybe raise depending on the study
um the the awards so I I think like if
we if we study it for real I think that
we could uh maybe get to a consensus all
Andrew thank you Mr chair I'm conflicted
with this whole
bill I was in favor of inim study but
listening to everyone and thinking about
it we do not live in the Middle Ages
it used to be to get information and I
know this for a fact because I go back
then you had to
maybe call somebody on the phone or you
may have had to go into some department
and look for information today is a
datadriven
country I just don't
believe that this information that we're
all looking for hasn't been presented
to us I mean I I don't look for excuses
because I don't accept
them here's been three months and we
when this came before us I swear we have
no more information now than when it was
introduced in the
Senate and how do we know that this
summer if there's such an issue coming
up with figures how do we know that an
interim study would even uh even count
or just be a waste of everybody's time
right now I'm going to vote against
instrum study and I may even vote
against the bill and they can bring it
back next year when somebody can come
forward with a lot more information
thank you all right any other yes
representative
gon thank you Mr chair one of the
advantages for an interim study would be
that we can get it right the first
time um there would be a hesitance if we
pass the bill now there would be a
hesitance to make any changes that might
be reasonable next term but we just
passed the bill let's see how this plays
out we may discover with with additional
information that we can repeal the
limits entirely and not be adversely
affected uh but well no we've already
put a limit on it and so then you'd get
the push back well you've passed this
limit let's let's see what happens so I
think we let's get one bill let's get it
put put the insurance commission on the
hook say get us the information if you
don't get the information then we're
just going to repeal the
limit other comments All right we guess
we're ready for a vote so the the motion
before interm study on Senate Bill 462
and i' would ask the clerk to call the
role Vice chairman Wallace yes rep
rep Stapleton
yes rep trip yes rep gon yes clerk kab
votes no rep
Perez rep
Smith rep Horgan no rep dorenzo no rep
Kenny no rep pige no rep Divine no rep
lonza no rep mano no repur
yes rep Ming no chairman Lynn
motion I'll move up out to pass all
second I would second it all right so
move by uh representative
Manos all right um anybody else wants to
be
heard yes representative
trip the uh the problem I have with this
bill is
is there's really no objetive evidence
for why the uh amounts were set to where
they
were
uh the
U
uh there's several States I understand
that have uh no limits which would make
more sense to me since then the amount
would have to be argued out in Court you
rather than just you know some number
that was you know picked out of the
stratosphere so uh that's essentially
why I'm going to oppose uh H to pass
thank you anyone else wish to be
heard all right so I guess we're the
motion then before us is ought to pass
and I'd ask the clerk to call the
role Vice chairman Wallace No rep
Alexander no rep Andrews no no rep
testerman
no rep Stapleton no rep trip no rep gon
no clerk cab votes yes rep
Perez rep Smith
yes rep Horgan yes rep D Lorenzo yes rep
Kenny yes rep paage yes rep Divine yes
rep lonza yes rep Manos yes repur
no rep Ming
yes chairman Lynn
to9 okay all right um so uh who wants to
write the majority report uh
representative Ming you all right and um
who wants to write The Minority Report
representative trip will you write the
you okay all right we're now on to um
House Bill uh Senate Bill 507 extending
the time to petition for uh a a new
trial in certain cases and um
representative Manos you have a motion
is that correct yes uh I have an
amendment which I circulated yesterday
all right so um represent man are you
moving your motion I am all right and do
right Smith and representative Manos do
you wish to speak to your motion uh yes
briely um Mr chair um the purpose of my
motion is to add to the Senate bill um
removing the time limit on filing a
motion for a new trial adding uh civil
cases um uh and again this is based on
newly discovered evidence or additional
forensic testing or new scientific
understanding um the reason I propose my
amendment is because it seems to me in
Congress
um to have the situation where somebody
could be exonerated of a crime for
example rape and um and um
assault uh based on newly discovered
evidence for example DNA testing
evolving um and that same person having
been found um civil liable um and in
that case not being able to f a motion
for a new trial based on the same change
in scientific evidence or scientific
understanding um it also seems in um uh
in congruous to me that for example a
person would be exonerated of the crime
but still be liable to pay a judgment
when there would be scientific evidence
that um that showed that the person did
not commit um the act for which they
have been held civil liable um and so
for that reason I propose that both um
um that both a judgment in a civil case
as well as a criminal conviction be um
applicable for um filing a motion for a
new trial without a time limit for new
scientific evidence right is there
anyone else wish to speak to this so I'm
going to i' I've say I'm I'm going to
oppose the motion for a couple of
reasons I mean basically because I I I
hope that we will end up getting to
interim study on the bill itself but um
with regard to the particular Amendment
um I I sort of understand where where
you're coming from uh representative man
but I think that it there's a I think
that there's a problem in trying to
equate criminal liability with civil
liability and criminal what we're
talking about generally with with with
regard to somebody who's been convicted
and normally it doesn't have to be but
usually it's somebody been convicted of
a serious crime as and is in jail you C
you want to get that person a new trial
um or maybe even a dismissal but at
least a new trial in the hopes that they
would be found not guilty and wouldn't
would no longer be in jail in the Civil
context
though you I think it's a much different
situation because you're talking about
private rights so let's
assume that I that you know party a
brings a lawsuit against party B and
recovers a million dollars um and then
sometime after three years later uh
there's some newly discovered evidence
uh well you know it's a much different
story to say we're gonna claw back I
mean suppose you know I suppose I've
recovered a million dollars from you and
three years later we find some um some
uh that says some new evidence it's a it
seems to me it's a much different situ I
mean you know if I've if if I've used
some of that money to send my kids to
college or whatever I mean I it
depending on how long has gone by it
seems to me there are many many
different factors that might enter into
that
uh that would go beyond simply was the
person liable originally so I have
problems with with that U but more
broadly the the the the other issue I
think with regard to with regard to this
whole bill is it's really important to
understand that the the
um the remedy that this seeks for
criminal cases of a new trial is not in
the overall scheme of things very
important because there is the
alternative avenue available of habius
Corpus and you might recall that when I
asked that of the witness the witness
said well you know habus Corpus cases
are your are usually brought in the
district where the institution is
located so if you're serving a sentence
in uh you know in the prison in Berlin
you would bring the case in Coos County
Superior Court where as a motion for new
trial would be brought where the trial
was held which might be Manchester as an
example
that that kind of issue is a big issue
in federal court
proceedings um there where where habus
Corpus motions are brought where the
institution is so you know when I was in
the US attorne of in New Hampshire that
Danbury was was often the closest
institution and so often um uh even for
New Hampshire prisoners uh they often
went to the federal correctional
institute in Danbury and so cases would
be brought in the havest cases in the
federal court in Connect
um whereas another kind of motion which
is in the federal system is known as a
2255 motion would come to the original
court but that's not that whole issue is
not really an issue in state practice
because the courts have ample authority
to transfer cases around they can always
send it back to the original judge and
often do that um in uh in in habus
Corpus cases depending on the issues
that are raised so at any rate that's a
long way of
saying I I don't have a problem with the
idea at least in criminal cases of
extending the the three-year limitation
but I think if we're going to I I think
it should be referred to interim study
because there's a problem with our
habius Corpus statutes too uh our case
law on hius Corpus is really kind of all
over the place and if we were going to
do if we were going to change this I
think it would make much more sense to
have us take a look at the whole
postconviction
relief uh system which would include
habius Corpus um and so I think that
um changing this right now is a bad idea
and I think that just making the change
from civil to to add civil I think that
there are we would potentially be facing
unintended consequences here that could
be could be significant so I I will be
voting against the
amendment representative
tur I I have a question and it's
probably more of the technical nature so
I may be addressing it to you or anyone
else in the in the instance of a civil
case not tied to some also criminal case
um is there is there history of civil
cases being
overturned um and if so would the person
who received the initial
award essentially now be liable for the
entire amount that they were were
awarded you know in other words to your
point if they do not have it would this
person who thought they had received an
award from the court system through a
trial now be essentially in the position
of having to pay back resources that
might they might leave them in a in a
deficit if that made sense you know it
it does and I think I mean I think it
is it is very
rare in civil litigation particularly
where a case has you know been tried
there's been a trial and a verdict in a
in a civil case it's pretty rare for a
motion for a new trial in those kind of
circumstances to be made more than three
years after the the um the Judgment has
been ra now is it absolutely impossible
no if you know if there was really sort
of a massive fraud of you know somebody
made a just a completely bogus claim and
could that happen I think probably it I
think probably it could um and maybe in
that kind of a case you know it would
you would say it would be worth it to to
to try to go after the person but I'm
I'm just concerned that
there's when you're talking about a
civil case you're you're talking about
balancing private parties interests and
those interests it seems to me can often
be um much more complicated in their
implications um than you know in the in
the criminal context if if somebody is
not if somebody if newly discovered
evidence reveals that somebody is not
guilty the the state the state doesn't
suffer any harm from releasing somebody
that's not guilty that's what that's
what you know that's what Justice is all
about so it's a much
less um if the person is really not
guilty it's a much there's much less
balancing in that context than it is in
the in the Civil context and so you know
there it may be that there would that
that we should extend the three years
for some civil Con in some civil context
maybe there should be some conditions on
it
all of all of that kind of thing I'm
just all I'm saying is it seems to me
that
this this requires more careful thinking
than what we just than just sort of
doing
it uh representative trip and then
representative
man it seems to me that
uh
uh in a uh civil
matter the uh
the uh the person that brought the
uh charges or whatever you want to call
it uh
lose then uh this would give them an
opportunity to bring the charges
again in a Crim in a criminal case in a
in a civil in civil case now say say
that the uh the uh the court judgment
went against them uh and they did not
get you you know uh uh what they
expected you know uh money or whatever
you know so if if uh if we do this then
uh three years later when something new
is discovered you know they would be
able to go back you know another swing
at the ball you know to say to uh get
you know money from uh whoever they were
uh litigating against would that be a no
no that's I mean no you raised a very
good point that's I was sort of thinking
about the you know recovery of a
judgment and then trying and then trying
to get that backed out but you're right
that would be you would be giving the
you would be giving the plaintiff uh
another bite at the Apple and you know
again in the Civil Contex it it seems to
me that there's a really fundamental
difference between criminal and civil if
the if somebody's in jail and shouldn't
be there um then that you know as I
think we heard from all of the witness
including the prosecutors I think
everybody say gez that's you know that's
a big problem um if you've had the
chance to bring your civil
case even if you know even if you didn't
get all the evidence that you should
have had or
whatever unless it's I would think that
unless there's really been a you know a
blatant
fraud um it's once you've had your day
in court it it's it's a you know your
claim to have another day in court it
seems to me is is generally much less
compelling than in the criminal context
that that's what I the way I would raise
it representative Vanos thank you Mr
chair I just I just wanted to add a
couple of thoughts one is that currently
the statute is three years um and for
both civil and criminal because there's
no there's no removal of the time limit
for the criminal cases so in the example
you gave earlier of you received a
judgment from me and you spent the money
on sending your children to college well
within 3 years I could file a motion for
a new trial under the current statute
and you would have spent the money but
the other thing I would add is it seems
very unfair to me um if you've been
exonerated criminally by new evidence
that for example if you're paying on a
judgment if I'm paying you monthly
$1,000 a month on a judgment that I
should continue to pay that to you when
I've been exonerated criminally and I
could not possibly have done whatever
I'm paying you $1,000 a month for and so
I just see that as as a an an
incongruous situation that doesn't seem
fair right well you know I I guess what
I I I I mean I understand what you're
saying but I guess you know just as an
example one of the things that
might be the distinct iction there is
remember
the you might be entitled to be
exonerated in a criminal case by new
evidence that raises the question of
whether you were guilty Beyond a
reasonable doubt that might not affect
the question of whether the evidence was
sufficient to make you civil liable by
the much lower preponderance of the
evidence standard so I mean it and and I
guess what I you know that the point
about I I understand you're right about
the three years now would apply if I
sent my kid to college within three
years but the problem I see is suppose
it's 20 years you know you got uh I
recovered a judgment against you I spent
the money and it's now 20 years
later my I've reordered my life and
whatever you know you could say well you
got this
windfall okay but all I'm saying is I
think it's much more complicated in the
Civil context and that maybe we ought to
look at it more carefully that's kind of
where I'm coming from other other
representative me thank you Mr chair I
would think that in in the case of a new
trial though you would you would take
all those factors into account the fact
that um if you had a big judgment that
you spent um and this is a decade or two
decades down the line you and you acted
reasonably right you had you acted upon
the evidence that you had you had the
the Civil judgment and you have you have
the money now and you spent it
um this is I would think that the
lawyers on both sides of the case would
take that into account and whether it's
the judge or the jury um they would also
take that into account so um and this is
you know potentially highly relevant
evidence um so I think it it deserves at
least a second look even if it's um
maybe not returning money it it would
possibly reverse a civil a civil
decision and um maybe that's of some
value to some people even if it's not
money right other com yes representative
tur yeah just just one last thought on
this and it comes from and I I I think
that the point about the different
burdens of proof of the different cases
is is interesting you know I I was
favorable to this I'm wavering I I would
say my thought would be if the if the
Civil judgment was tied to the criminal
case that the bill originally spoke to
you know it seems easier to justify
because it's tied to the same individual
that that is criminally responsible for
whatever the the situation situation is
and since that burden's higher if that
was to be overturned the criminal side
if the Civil side was tied to that would
make more sense but this sort of is more
open-ended than that the way I read it
it's open it basically says any civil
judgment versus versus a civil judgment
that is related to a a also a criminal
case so that makes makes it to me harder
to sort of justify that that tiered
system of of being able to step down to
a civil case and and reopen it
representative
K I think that this is a really
important bill
and I really think we need to interim
study it because I I I checked it into
the DNA statue and it really has a whole
bunch of other guardrails on it like
this doesn't even have anything about
you know you having to submit a petition
within a certain amount of time frame
after receiving the evidence it doesn't
have anything in here about successive
petitions on the same new evidence um I
know that we had asked the committee
researcher to kind of look into it and I
I think it was probably a big task so
they haven't given us the data yet I
just I really think it's a really
important bill and we should do it right
the first time and I'm not trying to
kick the can down the road on this one
but I do think it's a it is a task that
really needs to to spend some time
because as I'm hearing all these things
I do think I do I am hearing a lot of
good points and I hadn't even considered
the Civil part prior but I I do think we
really need to look into this and and
fix it and put something forward through
that's a little just comprehensive but I
do really appreciate R Mano bringing
forward this amendment and this idea
because I I absolutely agree with you if
if somebody's been exonerated from a
crime and is and is is paying out a
monthly sum to somebody and we know now
Beyond you know any doubt that they
absolutely didn't do it why should they
have to keep paying I I really I think
we we should look into this and I'd be
happy to join in and in doing the work
for it
so yeah that's kind of where I'm at
other representative
stapon yeah I have trouble with the
amendment I kind of feeling that uh
civil and criminal are two different
animals apples and oranges and it seems
like there's more apparency with civil
cases than with criminal cases because
we have books we have
records um you know you can subpoena
stuff um there's there's more meat
there's more substance in the civil case
generally whereas in a criminal case
there's a lot of hidden stuff Discovery
is difficult and um
you know there's a tendency to um hide
evidence spoliation um perhaps maybe
more than uh civil matter because of the
penalty impacts are so
severe uh I I think it needs the bill
needs further study to far it out all
aspects but I can't go with the with the
amendment because I think there's just
too different too much difference
between civil and
criminal other comments
all right I guess we're ready then for
uh the motion before us is uh to adopt
um representative Manos is uh Amendment
20241 1682 and I would ask the clerk to
call the role can we just get a second
on that oh do I'm sorry I thought we yes
uh we did we had as representative Smith
second oh okay perfect okay thank you
sorry about that Vice chairman Wallace
No rep Alexander no rep Andrews rep
testerman no rep Stapleton no rep trip
no rep gon no Clark votes no rep Perez
rep Smith yes rep Horgan yes rep D
Lorenzo yes rep Kenny yes rep page yes
rep Divine yes rep lonza yes rep Manos
yes rep tur no R Ming yes chairman Lynn
no
fails
um so uh now I would uh rep recognize
representative katab for a
motion I move in term study
representative Alexander you second yes
all right um representative katab do you
wish to say anything further I think
I've already covered I I think we really
need to take a deep dive into this and
and I think we could come up with a
really comprehensive Bill if we did and
I I think that there's you know once we
get some of the research back I think we
could really put together a good bill
so anybody else wish to be heard
representative tur yeah I'll just say I
I I think you know and again as a clean
bill just related to um criminal you
know uh trials where somebody is in fact
incarcerated the compelling evidence of
the ability to extend new uh technology
to exonerate somebody is important and I
think you know many of my original
concerns around the safeguards about the
frequency with which people might bring
these um requests you know and the
parameters you know from what I've
understood are addressed because they
would have to go through you know
Council or and through the the the judge
in the trial so I don't feel like it's
as open to abuse as um
as it might seem or at least it
initially seemed to me so I I would
would like to see a different
motion all right any anyone else wish to
be heard on that so I guess I I would
think particularly as limited to
criminal cases I think it's really I
can't emphasize strongly
enough that this three-year limitation
Because unless the person is not in
custody and being on parole or probation
is considered to be in custody unless
the person is not in custody um there's
a habus corpus remedy available and
that's used so you know they as you as
you may have heard I'm sure we've all
seen and heard in the paper there are
many many cases in New Hampshire where
somebody brings a postconviction uh
attack on their conviction way after
three years and it and they go you know
those and those are heard because
they're brought as Abus Corpus so this
three-year limitation it it doesn't you
know I'm I'm I'm not saying it never has
some um implication that I think there
probably are certain circumstances where
it does but the reason I would like to
see the interim study is I think it
would make sense to look at both the
habius Corpus and this new trial and
come up with you know uh a
more holistic approach I mean for
example one of the things that might
make sense is to say if
you're there's no there shouldn't be any
statute of limitations if your claim is
that you're actually innocent that you
were wrongfully convicted and you and
there and you should get a new trial or
you should get a rid of habius Corpus
that's one thing but the way it can be
um the way it can be used now including
habus corpuses it it it often it can can
be used in a circumstance where there
isn't really a claim of Innocence it's
that some there was some error not NE
not really going to innocence that
resulted in your conviction a a Fourth
Amendment violation or a Fifth Amendment
violation or something like that and I
think there should there's at least a
question about whether you should be
able to use it for that use those kind
of remedies for those purposes where
there's really not a claim that that
you're that you're actually innocent
it's just that you know the police
questioned me too long or something like
that yes representative Smith um thank
you very much for that explanation it it
helps a lot um what I want to point out
is if you are moving interim study
you're in moving interim study on the
bill that is before us and the section
two lines 5 through 8 would be the ones
that are in question if you um because
of your certainly Superior knowledge of
the judicial system in this state
believe that the time has come to
address problems of habus Corpus then I
commend that and think you should do
that and it has absolutely nothing to do
with interim study of this bill it has
to do with the time having come for new
legislation that would address habus
Corpus so that I don't quite see I I
wonder if you're conflating the two
issues here and they should be kept
separate one would be interim study of
Senate Bill 507 as amended by the Senate
and completely separate issue is how
cabus Corpus is handled in this state
thank you other yes representative
maners um would habus Corpus lie for
newly discovered um scientific evidence
oh yeah yeah absolutely it it would
absolutely it would yes and as as
so just to say I I mean I think that
these are
so
overlapping um that you know they really
are related because they're both they're
both what is referred to as
postconviction
relief um and and so they they really
are very very much related um and that's
why I think that you know it
it's it's hard to sort of if you wanted
to have a comprehensive solution it's a
comprehensive fix so to speak it's hard
to deal with one without the
other yes thank you Mr chair um would
habus Corpus in New Hampshire for a
state in in the state courts be limited
by our three-year limit
on um filing a motion for a new trial
based on
um scientific evidence scientific change
in science in other words would this be
a limitation on habus Corpus if in other
words if we were to pass this with it if
we would have passed the bill without
your Amendment would it be a limitation
on Abus Corpus no with dis regarding um
in other words currently there's a
three-year limitation maybe I'm I'm
misunderstanding this here so I just I
I'm kind of thinking out loud in other
words
[Music]
um is our three-year limitation would
that be viewed under habius Corpus as as
a
ceiling I think the the the short answer
is no but I but as I said before our
habius
Corpus jurist Prudence is to say that
it's complicated and not particularly
clear is would be an understatement but
there are certain cases I mean a lot of
cases in which the request for habus
Corpus relief was brought way more than
three years beyond the Beyond you know
beyond the conviction and many of those
cases not not all of them many of them
are dismissed for one reason or another
but many of them are do go forward um so
it's it's you know it's not the
three-year limitation is not like the
end of the
matter all right any other comments
yes represent
Stapleton I think I'm
troubled that evidence is described as
new as opposed to measuring any quality
weight um uh um material aspect of
evidence and in some of the discussion
we had previously on April the
10th representative Alexander made a
point that this could open up a flow of
petitions and if we don't
qualify the the qu quality weight um the
material aspect of evidence maybe that
could happen and now we have already a
flood a tight court docket behind and
short staffed and we could be in some
real trouble and therefore the interim
study needs to look at that aspect of
quality and weight of
evidence other comments I I just to
follow up I think you know as
representative kutab pointed out the the
deal there is a separate statute dealing
with DNA testing and that does have much
more specific criteria of needing to
make certain showings and things like
that and so um I think that's I mean I
think that is something that that
interim study would look at um whether
there should be something more uh in
that regard so I I I tend to agree with
you other
comments all right I guess the most then
is interim study and I would ask the
clerk to call the
role Vice chairman Wallace yes rep
Alexander yes rep Andrews rep testerman
yes re steton yes rep trip yes rep gson
yes clerk ofab votes yes rep Perez rep
Smith no rep orgon no rep D Lorenzo no
rep Kenny no rep page no rep divine
yes rep lonza no rep Manos no rep ter
no rep Ming no chairman Lynn yes motion
passes 11
to9 all right
[Music]
um 11 to nine all right so um
representative kab can I ask you to
write the report and um who will write
the uh
report do you want
to so okay great thank you
representative Manos sorry all right
last one do you wait oh of course oh
all right um
so okay so
um a a uh an important suggestion by the
clerk which I think is is very important
so I'm going to when I when I said
before I get your reports in by the end
of the day I like to make a slight
amendment to that how about get in to me
please get I just want to make sure that
we all know who's to blame for
[Laughter]
that three three o'clock you know these
I mean these don't have to be long uh
long reports that's for sure all right
we're on to the last bill
um uh Senate Bill uh 576 the chair
recognizes representative kab for a
motion I move on to pass is there a
second second seconded by representative
Wallace representative kab do you wish
to speak to your motion no all right uh
anyone else wish to yes representative
organ um well we I think we never really
heard why this bill was necessary if
there fact it's a problem with the dead
people voting um I know you I know from
personal experience and we probably all
had the experience of a family member
dying one of the things you do
immediately afterwards if you working
through a funeral home or crematorium
fill out a long huge stack of papers
there all kinds of different um entities
including the state of New Hampshire
have to be notified and this adds one
more to it which um I'm not sure why
it's necessary and also takes effect 60
days after its passage so I don't know
that really gives uh the parties such as
the funeral homes time to uh be notified
and that this is like one more thing you
have to make one more official copy of
the death certificate and one more thing
that the executive has to has to uh
submit submit at the time of death so I
would I'm I'm just I'm inclined to vote
vote against it although it's U it's not
it's not a terrible idea but I think I I
think I don't think I can vote for this
pH as as it's comes to us right uh
representative Smith and then
representative Perez thank you very much
this is um uh a bill that is absolutely
not
necessary um in fact the current uh
system that we have uh where the the
town clerks who report deaths um who who
get the reports of deaths the funeral
homes don't forget that not every death
involves an
executive um these figures are I mean
the deaths the these occurrences are
reported they're reported in time
they're reported under current
procedures all this is is to make
another hoopdee doop about how our
election system works it works very well
we don't have dead people voting um uh
unless they're able to Rise Up from the
grave and vote then give them credit and
let them vote um so that I am planning
to vote um against this bill as
completely unnecessary and I believe the
town and City Clerks will support that I
believe Health and Human Services would
support that and I believe the Secretary
of State's office would support that
thank you right anyone else wish to be
heard on the this bill all right I think
we're ready to oh I'm sorry represent
I Echo um representative Smith sentiment
and I believe that most towns do a
report um of deaths like life they do
reports on births deaths and marriages
in fact my own town has a report they
run it annually with the the death the
date of death and um the location of the
death so it seems unnecessary thank you
all right any any other comments all
right oh yes representative State I
support the the bill I think that even
if there are not a lot of occasions of
misuse
uh um people voting for for dead people
on absentee ballot that are um wrongly
obtained or utilized that this uh bill
is at least
precautionary so that we don't have a
problem and can clean up and tighten up
our record keeping relative to people
who have passed and the voting record
better all right any other yes
representative
Perez going to the town clerk does not
get it to the supervisor of the
checklist you cannot guarantee that the
supervisor of the checklist in some
towns don't meet very often we have a
bill right now trying to make them meet
more frequently so getting it to the
town clerk doesn't necessarily we had a
problem in londonairy we had over 1200
people still on the list that voted that
had moved out that or died and had um
voted in
2022 um they are now off the checklist
but hey it's 2024 oh they voted in 20
2020 it's now 2024 this is a
safeguard especially for small towns
thank you anyone else wish to be heard
on oh uh whoop representative Oregon did
you yes thank you for letting me speak a
second time and I hope I waited till
everyone else has spoken just from my
own personal experience my uh and you
were all very kind to me it happened my
mother passed away shortly before the uh
presidential primary and the last
conversation she had with me was that
she had indeed sent in her absentee
ballot so I think
um but that's a fairly that's a fairly
rare I mean it's not a unique situation
but it's fairly rare that she was
intending to be on January 23rd and she
ended up passing on January 16th and
um that's uh probably not something that
materially affects the results of the
election too much I guess in
theory the ballot could have been
challenged but also
um but the flip side of it is I guess
the other thing is if somebody dies and
then somebody comes in you know somebody
came in in person in a subsequent
election and claimed to be my mother um
we already have a voter ID thing and
other protections and so if that was
happening there's a high probability the
person would be caught and if it was
happening frequently there would be also
a high probability that there' be a lot
of irregularities on the checklist and
people watch those closely so I think I
think this bill is uh if the think this
bill this bill um solves a problem that
doesn't really exist I think it's
unnecessary and just creates more uh
just creates a little bit more uh
paperwork and for families who are in a
difficult situation already at the time
so thanks right representative M did you
have some yes please yes I just wanted
to mention that um it's not clear to me
how a personal representative or an
executive would be notified yeah um of
this obligation that they have and how
it would be
enforced and so I will be voting against
this bill but it's not clear to me how
how the executive or personal
representative would be notified or how
they would how they would know of their
obligation any other comments oh
representative
Anders thank you Mr chair would somebody
please
clarify I'm not exactly sure on the data
I understand all the data goes
in and clerks and everybody has access
to it if they have access to it why
records representative Perez only
because we've had an issue in londondary
the town clerk no one in the town has
any jurisdiction over your supervisor of
the checklist the only person who has
any jurisdiction over the supervisor of
the checklist is the secretary of state
so therefore therefore it doesn't
necessarily go from the clerk to them
and it doesn't necessarily get taken off
nobody is double checking that so I know
that from experience this would be a
safeguard and how they would know of it
is funeral parlors give you a list of
all the things that that you were going
to need to do and this would just be
added to it in my in my opinion thank
you any other comments All right so the
U motion is ought to pass and I would
ask the clerk to call the role please
Vice chairman Wallace yes rep Alexander
yes rep Andrews
no rep testerman yes rep Stapleton yes
rep trip yes rep gon yes Clark kab votes
yes rep Perez yes rep Smith no rep Horan
no rep D Lorenzo no rep Kenny no rep
pagee no rep
Divine no rep lonza no rep Manos no
repur no rep Ming no chairman Lynn yes
um is there another motion Mr chair I'm
I move itl all right I'm try second okay
all right um represent Smith do you wish
to speak to your motion no thank you all
right anyone else wish to be heard all
right then I would ask the clerk to
please call the role on the motion of
inexpedient
Alle Vice chairman Wallace No rep
Alexander no
rep Andrews yes re testerman no rep
Stapleton no re trip no rep gon no clerk
have votes no rep Perez no rep Smith uh
yes rep Horgan yes rep D Lorenzo yes rep
Kenny yes rep Paige yes rep Divine yes
rep lonza yes rep Manos yes rep tur yes
rep Ming yes chairman Lynn no
to9 all right so
uh
you all right and will there be a
Minority Report representative Alexander
all right I think
um I think we're done so you know what
let me can I just just yes
representative Tri so having the reports
done by three could you explain what
done means does
done to me done means to you means send
them to me which means it doesn't mean
that it has to be to the clerk but no no
no it needs it has to be to me has to be
to me so you know what let me can I just
take a minute to return this receipt by
250 can I just review so make sure that
we're all on the same page so on a on
Senate Bill 185 the reports will be uh
by representative Alexander and
representative Lan lonza on uh
143 uh the report will be by myself and
representative Smith 4313 four four 43
the 413
right oh sure
sorry didn't clearly okay so
on13
right uh you're doing the otpa right and
I'm doing OTP you're doing OTP right
okay yeah I just wanted to make sure
that sure confused or I am completely
confused but right Le I know no problem
then on 422 the report will be uh by
representative Smith on the otpa with
Amendment
1697 and representative Alexander on
otpa with Amendment
1698 on uh
462 uh the report will be by
representative Ming for the majority and
representative trip for the minority on
uh 507
the interim study report will be by
representative katab for interim study
and representative Manos in the minority
and um lastly on uh
576 the um itl will be by representative
Smith uh for the majority and
representative Alexander for the
minority and please just if you get them
to me by 3 o'clock uh that I'll try to
turn them around and make them short
please short okay so let know the other
thing I want to say this this is I think
our last time before uh be uh for in
committee think because I think we're
done with our work so I want to thank
everyone for all your service uh uh I
really appreciate all your efforts and
I'm I think we've still think we have
the best Committee in the house and uh
okay M MRK can can I also say as as we I
think did last last session or last year
um I just wanted to thank um you as the
chair and representative Smith as the
ranking member for you know as my first
term in this in this body working
through a lot of really difficult issues
in a really you know uh collaborative
and and high-minded way so I appreciate
it well thank thank thank you very much
for thank you and my hero my hero of
this committee is our clerk
Caitlyn been outstanding
that's for sure that's for sure all
right thank thanks everybody and I just
want I mean if in fact the Senate sends
bills back that have been amended right
we will have to chat about yes
absolutely a heads up speaking on that
matter House Bill 103 the name change
Bill there was one small amendment that
they had to make to say while somebody's
incarcerated that in addition to the
Department of Corrections being notified
the department of safety would notified
for somebody's background check it's
going to be how the Senate is going to
basically send that over while we're in
session because the several of the
victim families are going to be in the
Senate and they were going to recognize
them there like the the girl who was
killed her parents are coming up from
massachus the woman that was murdered
her children are coming her two
daughters are coming from Connecticut
and New Jersey so they're going to
reconsider it right then so they and
send it over yeah just while the
families are there to not make them have
to make another trip so I'll just move
to just move to confer
okay and they're gonna get something I